Deep learning frameworks,
assemble hello world,
it's Raj and there are so many
deep learning frameworks out there.
How are you supposed to
know which one to use?
I'm going to compare 10 of the most
popular deep learning frameworks in this
video across a wide variety of metrics
from ease of installation to performance
to popularity on get hub.
After reviewing the merits and drawbacks
of each of them will be able to come to
some kind of reasonable
conclusion at the end.
So let's start with the obvious one.
Tensor flow.
Out of all the deep learning frameworks,
tensorflow is without a doubt the most
popular in terms of developer activity on
get hub who will created it to help power.
Almost all of it's massively scaled
services like Gmail and translate,
then open sourced it for the rest of us.
Nowadays,
recognizable brands like Uber,
Airbnb and Dropbox have all decided to
leverage this framework for their own
services. Currently it's best
supported client language is python,
but there are also experimental interfaces
available in c plus Plus Java and go
and because it's so popular
it has bindings for other
languages like c sharp and
Giulia created by the
open source community.
Having such a massive developer community
has resulted in tensorflow having rich
detailed documentation not only from its
official website but from various third
party sources from around the web.
This documentation covers its various
features like tensor board cancer board
lets developers monitor
the model training process,
the various visualizations and
it's a crucial part of it's sweet.
Another crucial part is tentraflow
serving which allows developers to easily
serve their models at scale
in a production environment
and includes distributed
training.
Tensorflow lite even enables on device
inference with low latency for mobile
phones,
but despite all of this
tensorflow is pretty low level.
You have to specify a lot of magic
numbers like the number of layers in your
network,
the dimensions of your input data,
and this requires a lot of boiler
plate coding on the developer's part,
which can be tedious and difficult.
By default.
Tensorflow lets developers create static
computation graphs at compile time.
We must define it,
then run it,
meaning all the conditions and iterations
in the graph structure have to be
defined before it's run.
If we want to make any changes
in the neural network structure,
we have to rebuild it from scratch.
It was designed this way for efficiency,
but a lot of the newer neural
architectures dynamically change,
so this default define and run mode of
tensorflow is counterintuitive and can
make the bugging difficult.
They did add a define Byron option
called eager execution later on,
but it's not native.
Expect it to be even better in TF 2.0
which is about to release most of the time
tensorflow is compared
to the Pi Torch Library,
a native define Byron framework.
Pi Torch was created by Facebook to help
power it services and it's now used by
brands like Twitter and salesforce.
Unlike tensorflow though your
income high torches default defined,
Byron mode is more like
traditional programming while
training a Pi torch model
for each iteration in an epoch.
A computational graph is created after
each iteration. The graph is freed,
meaning more available memory because
it defines the graph in a forward pass
versus a defined then run
framework like tentraflow.
Backpropagation is defined by how the
code is run and every single iteration can
be different.
Pi Torch records the values as they
happen in our code to build the dynamic
graph as the code is run high torch.
Also nails debugging.
We can use common debugging tools like
PDB or Pi charm and the modeling process
is simple and transparent.
High Torch has declarative data,
parallelism features a lot of pretrained
models and has modular parts that are
relatively easy to combine
and just like tensor flow.
It allows for distributed training.
On the flip side, however,
a Pi torch lacks model serving in the
well thought out way that tensorflow does
and lacks interfaces for monitoring
and visualization like cancer board,
but you can connect Pi Torch to tensor
board via some third party libraries like
cancer board x. If we look at
various papers from neuro hips,
the biggest AI summit of the year,
it's clear that researchers tend
to prefer Pi Torch to tensorflow.
That's because it's best for
prototyping or small scale projects.
When it comes to larger
across platform deployments.
Tensorflow seems to be the better option,
but I should also note that the popular
cafe two framework introduced by
Facebook in 2017 is built for mobile and
large scale deployments in production
environments and was recently
merged into Pi torch.
This gives pie torch production grade
scalability. Curiously, deep mind.
Perhaps the most prominent AI research
lab in the world doesn't use Pi torch.
They use their own framework
called Sonnet, which is
built on top of tensorflow.
Deep minds.
Developers spent a lot of time having to
acquaint themselves with the underlying
tension flow graphs in order to
correctly architect their applications.
But with Sonnet,
the creation of neural net components
was made easy because at first constructs
python objects, which represent
some part of a neural network.
Then separately connects these
objects into the computation graph.
These modules simplify the training
process and can be combined to implement
higher level networks.
Developers can also easily extend Sonnet
by implementing their own modules.
This makes switching
between models easier. Well,
let's put the research versus production
pipeline debate aside for a second.
What if you're just a beginner and just
want to learn how all this stuff works?
The minimalist python based library
called Karrass can be run on top of
tensorflow or Microsoft's CNTK care.
Ross has support for a huge range of
neural network types and makes prototyping
dead simple and the code is very readable.
That's the reason I use
it as a teaching tool.
So often in my videos it's
really easy on the eyes building.
A massively complicated deep learning
model can be done in just a few lines of
code.
It has built in support for training on
multiple GPS and can be turned into flow
estimators and train on
clusters of gps on Google cloud.
But the downside of it being so high
level is that it's not as customizable.
It's also constrained to the libraries.
It's built on like tensorflow, NCN, TK,
so less functionality than a lower
level library like tensorflow,
but easier to learn. Carrots is the
best learning tool for beginners.
All right, let's move on
to mx net. Jeff basis.
I mean Amazon's deep learning framework.
Mx Net has been adopted by AWS.
Parts of apalled are rumored to be
using it and it offers APIs and a huge
variety of languages natively.
Even Pearl,
where mx net excels is in its ability to
scale linearly more so than tensorflow.
The CTO of Amazon published benchmarks
for mx nets training throughputs using
the inception v3 image analysis algorithms
and claim that the speedup obtained
by running it across multiple gps
was very linear across 128 GPUs.
Mx Net performed a hundred
times faster than a single GPU.
Mx Net has a high performance
imperative API, which is pretty awesome.
It's got to simplicity of carrots
and it's dynamic like Pi Torch,
which makes debugging a lot
easier. Unlike Pi Torch, however,
mx net supports hybridization as
part of its glue on interface.
The hybrid block class seamlessly
combines declarative programming like
tensorflow and imperative programming
like Pi Torch to offer the benefit of both
users can quickly develop an debug models,
would imperative programming and switch
to efficient declarative execution by
simply calling hybrid
blocked dot hybridize.
We'll notice mx net advantage and symbolic
Api APIs when training on many gps in
some specific cases glue on his
three x faster than Pi Torch.
But take this with a grain of salt as
benchmarks depending on so many factors
and it's integration with AWS
is unbeatable because Duh,
it's Amazon's own pipeline.
Let's not forget Microsoft though CNTK
or Microsoft cognitive toolkit is a DL
framework that supports python
c plus plus c sharp and Java.
It's got support for CNNS and rns and
it's using Skype as Xbox and Cortana.
It's targeted toward letting developers
easily build models for products in
speech and image problems and it
offers support for Apache spark.
It's the easiest of all the frameworks
who integrate into a zero Microsoft's
cloud offering.
And one thing in particular I like
about CNC K is that it handles passing
sequences of varied length better
than the other frameworks. In TF,
you have to do padding masking and
sometimes even write your own softmax
function that ignores mask elements.
In Pi Torch,
the scenario is less painful with
functions like pack petted sequences,
but you still have to
pat at the beginning.
Masking in general makes your
model vulnerable to errors.
In CNC k you just have to
pass the sequence without
any padding or requiring a
mask later on and
everything is taken care of.
It handles sequences a
variable length internally.
Some of the criticisms of CNTK include
it's strict license as they have not
adopted conventional open source
licenses like GPL, ASF or MIT.
The community seems to consist of mostly
windows developers who would like to
include machine learning models in either
desktop or mobile applications. Also,
shout out to chainer a framework
created by a Japanese startup.
It's similar to Pi Torch and that
it has a native imperative Api,
but it's difficult to debug.
The community is relatively small,
but it's supported by giants like IBM,
Intel and in my fantasies make a Godzilla.
It can be run on multiple gps with
little effort and the main use case we've
seen thus far is in speech recognition,
machine translation and
sentiment analysis. If you're
core programming languages,
Java definitely take a look
at deep learning for j.
It's written mainly for Java and Scala
and supports a huge variety of neural
networks.
It was made for enterprise scale and
works with Apache Hadoop and spark on
distributed CPU and Gpu is also,
their documentation is stellar.
Java isn't very popular among
machine learning project,
so it's hard to integrate
it with other ml libraries.
Perhaps the main utility here is that
android apps are usually written in Java.
Thus this would be a good choice if
you'd like to build a full stack Java
pipeline,
which includes android devices and
speaking of mobile chat out to core ml.
It's not a framework that's made
to build models necessarily,
but it does help you bring existing
models built in other frameworks to apple
devices, and last but not
least, let's talk about onyx.
A Pokemon with a pretty high HP,
but also the open neural
network exchange format.
It was developed in partnership
between Microsoft and Facebook.
They both decided there was a need
for interoperability in the AI tools
community.
Since developers often find themselves
locked into one framework or ecosystem,
onyx enables more of these tools to
work together by allowing them to share
models.
The idea is that you can train a model
with one tool stack and deploy it using
another for inference and prediction.
To ensure this kind of interoperability,
we must explore our model
into the onyx format,
which is a serialized representation of
the model in a proto buff file. Overall,
choosing the perfect framework
for a DL project can be hard.
You have to take into account many factors
like the type of architecture you'll
be developing with which programming
language you're going to use,
the number of tools you need, et
cetera. Here are my conclusions.
If you're a beginner to
programming in general,
use care us as it's still the
easiest library to learn from.
If you'd like to build a production,
great application and deploy it
to Google cloud, use tensorflow.
If you'd like to do research,
use high torch,
but also checkout sonnet if
you prefer deploying to AWS,
use mx net if you want
to deploy to Azure Ucn,
t k if you're a Java developer.
The planning forJ is your best bet,
I don't think has got anything unique
compared to the other frameworks.
And once you've already
started building a model,
use onyx to use tools from other
framework ecosystems with it. Oh,
and anything ios related you can
leverage core ml for what's your favorite
framework.
Let me know in the comment section and
please subscribe for more programming
videos. For now, I've got to define
and run, so thanks for watching.